youssef you're a doctor mate I want abs
by next month at a canyon can you sort
that there's nothing we can do but give
us the right fitness client get your
shredded I'm an Indian PT I'm sick of
this I'm sick of my clients giving me
for the flu I want to work in my socks
and my pants I don't want to do this
anymore we have an hour for you to
explain to people should they go online
do they need to have PT experience first
how do they do it and give us your best
stories don't build a program don't get
a website don't make a logo you guys
work in an industry of charlatans why
it's just it's money it's profit but it
says personal training you back so
everybody in PR Jim thinks that's the
guy go speak to high person with
personal trainer on their t-shirt I want
a personal trainer exactly nowhere else
on the planet does that happen when you
move into the internet really anybody is
a client because most people or in you
says world everybody has a bodybuilding
goal they just don't realize it
are you more talent into coaching
coaches or are you more talented
coaching clothing
ladies and gentlemen welcome back I'm
joined by dr. Ned Flanders finally holy
Johnny from Youssef Johnny Johnny from
Youssef Johnny and Yusuf the Robert
Verdi do you mean to do that
no that's incredible Johnny from Yusuf
and Yusuf he looks like Ned Flanders to
the people that are listening Yusuf has
grown a mustache for Movember and he
looks
I've been likened to every famous figure
with a mustache over the month apart
Thomas Alec have you captain who are
very Captain Hook at the moment actually
did he ever like oh yeah yeah if we get
you a hat read co-write Crash Bandicoot
you know the probably got hubli game
without googling it did he have a chain
on his jeans yes yes yeah blue denim
shorts red shoes and when I saw the show
Mike did this to me the other day and he
doesn't have a chain but it just shows
the power of suggestibility I was like
look yeah and then we looked at him up
and he never has a chain he like so
that's why I'm thinking Captain Hook
maybe didn't know thank you okay today
we're going to talk about how to be an
online coach this is what Jon your new
subdue the new wing of propane is
propane business butane you also have a
new podcast we do the propane business
podcast I mean I don't it's not
technically called that what a call if
you search propane business on iTunes
you'll get it is called or grow your
online fitness business the reason that
it's not called the propane business
podcast is there are a group of people
who make money from selling propane via
a business as a result they over do we
don't they do on the demand they thought
they wanted to sell it for thirty six
thousand dollars to us when we said yeah
propane business for people who want to
get into the butane in the same business
yeah you know Hank from king of the hill
yeah that's what he does he's in the
propane business these accessories for
you okay propane and propane accessories
so there will be some people listening
who think I mean
in gym PT I'm [ __ ] sick of this I'm
sick of my clients giving me the flu I
want to work in my socks and my pants I
don't want to do this anymore
it's kind curat I'm just gonna I'm just
gonna open the floor to you guys we have
an hour for you to explain to people
should they go online should they do
they need to have PT experience first
how do they do it and give us your best
stories so where do we start
you're doing in NRT of someone who's
about to go online maybe okay coach Wade
you stuck
you should scroll the answers for this
so with this I think that's a important
observation if I want to work in my
socks and pants I hope my sounds silly
but it is actually like you need to
think how do you want your life to look
day to day and so a lot of people don't
do this and they just feel like ah I'm
interested in like lifts biceps and
stuff so I'm gonna go and do a personal
training qualification and they realize
the reality of it is working in fewer
gyms or slinking around and like
sneezing on people to try and like gain
new clients and working long hours
exchanging time for money and generally
just having a bit of a rubbish time
whereas if you set your goal on how I
want my life to look and then
reverse-engineer it rather than I like
this and so I'm gonna do this and I'll
think about what the outcome ends up as
you can so people might like the idea of
being on the feed
talking interacting one-to-one or
nutcase but you're at berate a great fit
for a PT quite a lot of people don't
want to be exclusively online for that
reason because if especially if you've
gone from being an online coach being an
offline coach to full online so that
ironically sedentary yeah fixed by those
that go you go from waking up at 6:00 in
the morning and like non-stop till 9:00
at night and suggest you wake up in your
laptop open all descend email leave
actually spoken to an online coach we're
not gonna say his name but at the end of
an interview with him he was like so
I've been coaching people online to get
shredded for for ages but look at me and
he stood up lifted up his shirt and just
went like
is like fossils he was like it doesn't
matter
no one knows so very well-known guy as
well so let's say that someone the most
common person I think that's going to be
listening or that's gonna be interested
the most representative example for
people who are coaches is going to be an
Indian PT hmm maybe been a PC for three
years good clients yep
but they've realized hang on unless I
start putting my price up to 50 60 70
units per hour the 15 minutes yeah are
you tooling meters per hour kilowatt
hours oh yeah and they're like I want to
enter money what do they do yeah so the
biggest mistake that people make in that
transition is they think being an online
coach is the same as being an offline
coach so when you are like in pure gym
with the words personal trainer in on
your back they you don't realize it but
pure gym have done all of the work for
you like they brought the people to the
door they made them pay which is a big
deal because you've all you're dealing
with is people who are paying for
fitness which might just be there and
not creep and you've got a words on your
back that say you're the expert anyone
you can have a [ __ ] clue but it says
personal training debug so everybody in
PR gym thing you know that's the guy go
speak to yeah and people still struggle
that person is struggling I like I've
only got 20 clients so you couldn't have
a bit [ __ ] 6:00 in the morning 9:00 at
night don't see my friends that weekend
I know I'll go online what do people
want a recipe book that's what everyone
wants them on a recipe book so I'll make
a recipe book I'll make a low girl spend
five run on a website and I'll just try
and do the same thing on the Internet
and the analogy we use is you're like
but you're the pervert the family
barbecue because everyone's scrolling
down that's like cat photo cat photo
funny video brexit brexit baby baby
there's someone try something I'm gonna
[ __ ] off like BAM thwok yeah him play
and like they're like I don't have
anymore ten spaces so you know comment
below target target it's just not it
doesn't work so basically in the curve
market online market or probably any
industry if you just shoot from the hip
and try and sell fat loss in the
internet like because we were able to do
that when we started but on 2008 it was
because I pre corrupt-free that credit
crisis
that's because did you cause the credit
rose a sickly yeah we post on Facebook
imposes like that was in back in the day
it was beautiful where you could person
on Facebook and get 200 likes for rich
for sharing like a Daily Mail article
you would you could rank on the first
page of Google for writing an article
about Dom's or Ramadan or like we're
actually know Oprah even about like much
more basic stuff from that like
hypertrophy how do you have yeah top
page of I wonder I want a hypertrophy
Google preferred yeah first page Google
whereas now you just weren't much more
sophisticated well or just you know
there's a wider markets the markets
massive and there there are easily
enough clients to go around with hey
Siri anyone me what I've heard you are
you leaning on your iPhone which can we
turn it off now moving on the markets a
lot more system are Qatar gets massive
but there are a lot more people trying
to do because a lot more people are
disillusioned with PT offline so you
just have to be more specific with with
who tried to reach and that gone yeah
well that that's interesting that like
the the bottleneck is sales when you're
working in the pure gin but they don't
realize it because most of the the
front-end works been done but then when
they go online the bottom like is much
harder and if it's still sales but yeah
people think is the recipe book or
whatever and I think part of the problem
is thinking identifying the wrong
bottleneck with your whole process and
then trying to fix it and the most
common one is like I'm a PT and after on
me level 4 octave IQ certification then
I've got me not some level 1 and we're
gonna do me advanced nutritional
counseling for for women aged between 60
and 65
to help with with food and tolerances
and I've done me celiac certification
and we pregnancy level it's like because
they think it's like little feathers to
the extremes to the cup and casas skin
off their nose whatever and we're ours
like I would say any of that education
is that should be off your own back for
your own sense of internal pride and
really get out from a textbook don't pay
like to Bradford that's the same person
who says like you know Joe Wix is it you
know tosser and he doesn't know anything
so no one cares if Joe Wix has a
kettlebell well number three look at the
numbers yeah look a lot more people care
about drove it because there's no recipe
book it does have a recipe very bright
so he does so back to why that's
important and I'll get onto the recipe
book in a second the what peeler Jim
have done is brought a certain person in
they trust they trust the environment
they're in they don't like they don't
approach a PT and thing like how I get
scammed here if this in as an
environment you have to create all of
that yourself online because you've got
the institutional yeah you're in a gym
legit you know Jim it's a brand everyone
knows who you are but you trust the
Tesco guy you go to Tesco and you don't
think that's what yeah I need to find
out where the cereal isn't he says I'll
like Batman symbol Q and I'm not sure if
you know what you're talking about
and it's like a green button that says
auto car yeah are you sure exactly and
then like your website your persona
online everything has to create that so
you have to somehow be seen as trusted
as an expert as having the answers by
someone and the easiest way to do that
is to pick a specific person who
wouldn't actually see you as that I
realize I'm going round the houses here
but the point is like really there was a
weird noise and then we started working
with students because we just finished
being students and because we intimately
understood students so - a student
us versus you know a coach who's 10
years older or whatever we're much more
likely to be seen as an expert because
we know exactly what they're going
through we've had result
in that environment and our markets
changes we've grew up growing up and you
know we now make me work with people who
are where we were before we lives in a
propane with just finance and corporate
busy mm-hmm
so it's far easier to create that pure
Jim feeling when you're seen as someone
who's just our they get me then it's
done me so they're saying things that
are relevant you need to be seen with
some Authority you need to be trusted
and what was the third one well know
like and trust is like the thing that's
no lie they no knees trainer who you are
they trust you and they like you so you
know if they make you laugh if they're
if it's engaging they relate to what
you're saying it's super interesting
that you talk about how the offline
normal engine PT environment has
pre-selected for that now it's a Louis
housemate who's upstairs at the moment
he was at the gym
and I don't really know the way that
their PT structure is set up but they
have no rental costs for being in the
gym they just need to do I think it's
six hours of reception per week yeah and
I thought wow that's an amazing deal
when you actually scale up six hours by
for over a month at forty pounds per
hour or whatever you're gonna charge all
right hang on a second
mm I could maybe be working more but
then you think well I mean I can slot
things around it but the main thing and
this is what I was saying him you start
talking do I go into a private studio
should I go away how's that bro but if
you've got swaps left in your calendar
of slots left in your weekly schedule as
I would just stand on reception these
people are the hottest leads in the
world they're coming to you and saying
hi person with personal trainer on their
t-shirt I want a personal trainer
exactly nowhere else on the planet does
that happen apart from like the Yellow
Pages back in 1992
do you not when you look down that you'd
be like Arthur Andersen painter oh well
he's first top of the pitch it's even
better than that because the people in
the gym like they're by definition
they're series because they're paid to
be there so I hope you get enough sell
is it up sell not yeah yeah yeah so like
me
PTIN like a david lloyd like you know
one thing for sure about everybody in
there and i was that they're paying a
decent monthly right is a good point
like the quality is great because
they're in the gym like they're not
they're not just paid to offset their
guilt and haven't gotten in they didn't
actually turned up at the gym yeah yeah
yeah massive okay i mean they still have
a sales problem we're talking to people
who are probably offline PT's or people
are just interested in this industry
overall but are there any analogous
situations for this i guess someone
potentially who's like a counselor who
works one-to-one with people patel
perhaps doing therapy or anyone else
who's like that who's thinking about
going online do you think that these are
universal rules are at least like
applicable to some other or have you
considered any other yes i mean i think
any freelance job so yeah counselor
painter therapist an online painter well
like anything anything where there is a
potential to be working with an
institution or working on a city
understood on it so so either with PT if
you if you choosing to be purely offline
then you're either yet working with the
institution of pure gym or you have your
own personal brand that you've built and
then you can bring people into that and
then you offer whatever you want with
that if you're a painter you can't do
the lot online unless you go into like
information product but we don't know
how what the market is like for
information products for painters how to
be a painter how'd it be a painter feel
like a handyman or something but what
you can do is leverage your time and use
that expertise to say right I'm gonna
build a team around me and just after
being painted my focus on media yeah you
put born begins nothing afters with each
other so if you're if you're a handyman
the biggest market I see I'm showing you
you'll have experienced this pet right
we will we will experience this pain
horribly is there's a huge gap for pas
for handyman or for builders where they
just tell them right you're here on
Tuesday you're there on Thursday that's
where you go so effortful the discussion
Rakatan falls with anyone who's in the
handyman plumber painter carpenter
[ __ ] electrician thing like trades
ring the person hi mate can you do this
job are you available all this time
here's the address
here's the phone number of the person
who you need to speak to or it's me or
hang on I need to rearrange like none of
that has got anything to do with your
expertise as a [ __ ] hand me my the
thing is though is that that so that
will exist through bigger companies but
it'll be a lot more expensive and like
would you pay double because you gonna
pay for the PA and deployment that's it
so if you can charge like a 1020 percent
premium or whatever it is to cover your
costs and then just operate that at
scale and and a [ __ ] it what we're
talking about coaches for the
electrician's where the gap PMO's where
the gap will help you it is is creating
a piece of software make a SAS product
that is force a trade software as a
service so create a platform that
organizes arrangement yeah uber the
trains we're ready to meet back to
someone else deal up my trusty trader
and my trader and stuff like that doing
sourcing of it checked red.com but not
checkatrade organizing of it
you had your lot of tvw it's actually
more of a radio thing that is so much
radio we told an entire room of radio
presenters the only time we ever listen
to radio is before our Bluetooth connect
thank you for like the bosses will have
a big radio company conglomerate yeah
yeah technically yeah think of a big
radio station the owners of them we told
them that radio was their [ __ ]
immediately after someone told them that
93% of people in the UK listen to radio
at least once a week and we looked at
each other and went okay so I'm gonna
I'm thinking about how a sales page
works here where's your authority why
should the people that we're speaking to
listen to you that's like what what what
what what license have you got to talk
to anyone about how to be a nun really
question and it's also what you should
ask yourself whenever you're offering a
service is like how I achieve the thing
which I'm professing the receive the
result that I'm perfect professing that
I'm gonna get for other people and
so the same way that you wouldn't trust
a fat personal trainer you wouldn't
trust to cut a car driving instructor
that fast you have to and and the great
thing is you don't need to be the
world-record-holding authority on that
thing you just need to be a chapter
ahead of whatever you're offering so on
how many chapters I do think you guys
are because I've I know the answer to
this we probably look at the entire book
probably the Encyclopedia now I'm joking
we might be people who like us five
years ago my gosh ten years ago but
you've done a lot in five years you did
a lot more than most people were sure
yet taken so you've been online coaches
for ten years so wheat so pro pen start
'add about a decade ago as a blog gained
traction
got he clients slowly trickled along we
figured out right we need to figure out
how to market this bought a bought like
our first course to learn like the
basics and then since then of I mean I
don't know how much money you've
invested it would profit may six news a
grant as Morden that's way more than
that I actually hit clued although like
software stuff yeah so lots of money in
learning how to market it we've been
doing it can't hot spenders look as
tuition fee as well that it's nausea
would be sick yeah so we've been doing
it full-time I mean you've you've done a
bit of other stuff like you did a
medical degree and Blackrock blood yeah
but since 2016 full time so we're not
like I think our selling point as far as
we see it is there are two ways to
succeed with this stuff really
one is you hit so the bigger the best
example of the way that we don't do is
James Smith and what's up to him so he
let's talk about that in a second okay
all right
so we we don't have any of that if
anyone follows us like don't don't know
that we don't have five hundred thousand
followers on Instagram or anything like
that but not internet personalities no
yeah no
we we run things very much from any eye
we have systems that do the work for us
we figured we figured it out I suppose
they long for trading way that you know
if you leverage sales and marketing
properly you can use advertising
software systems to bring clients in and
in a fairly repeat of lawyer passive
yeah it's worth it there's a lot more
work to get it set up
but there's more predictability over it
it's less like will my video go viral
yes I know he'll the platform change and
take likes comments away there's none of
that but there is there's other other
uncertainties and difficulties it's
probably the difference between like
setting upper and intricate set of pipes
and stuff that spits out like a bowl of
cereal at the end and you and you just
go I'm going to pull that much milk into
the top and it goes it makes the bowl of
cereal compared to just getting your
hose pipe out and just polite and hoping
a bit goes in the bottle yeah yeah and
sometimes the loads goes in yeah
sometimes I know Stacey great yeah
Thursday's my best okay so you talked
about some of the things that you guys
have done I want the listeners the ones
who are still with us who are not
perfectly interested in what you don't
like or just I want to hear a round
robin for the next 10 to 15 minutes of
the funniest situations you've
encountered whilst learning about being
an online coach so I want to hear and
the fails I want to hear the story about
when you want to go see James Smith live
and you thought he was gonna give you
the keys I wanna hear this I want to
hear the story about the story about I'm
not being funny right
I wonder hear the one about the great
problem these really like looking and
getting he's getting firmer study big I
can't flex my hip quit so these actually
come very much into that what we're
saying about getting unites level 3
Kappa Bell certification all this stuff
that you go to like some kind of like an
Eric Helms
event which some of the people want this
thing who's that from Johnny for the
people who don't know who Eric Helms's
or surreally muscle journey yeah so so
like someone who he's a PhD researcher
and body builder talks about the the
mechanisms and physiology of muscle
metabolism and hypertrophy he's a big
deal he's a big deal even it but it's
very it's something that personal
trainers love to nerd out on and we did
as well like we turned up and I you know
there's some stuff about this but the
kind of questions that you have
you have people asking so what why are
we there why move people so there's an
online coach yeah there's not a coach
who's listening to this and thinking I
might go to Jim Smith's new training
seminar I might go to Eric houses new
this am I going home or to new whatever
and why do people go what do they want
well services I think it's a good but
yeah they they want the the secret the
thing and the questions that they're
asking if it's on behalf of clients it's
like you don't need to be asking that
it's just what I saw so like client she
period but normally she's got seventy
two point five kilogram this week
Tuesday she's got 70 kilogram for forums
she cannot do more is this
because can you stop creating on period
when you get so bogged down and like
it's not gonna help you get more clients
not gonna help you be a better personal
trainer or better anything and you see
you can see cuz the obviously these
people have been are seized questions
and lots and you watch like sometimes
like I should period question well
there's an archetype of someone goes
alright yes I do have a question
pertaining as soon as someone says
pertaining or like implement eight yeah
or anything like that
red red flag warning this set the clocks
and goes off do you remember if someone
opens up with a title that they have so
like
as a personal trainer of 15 yeah yeah I
absolutely love that do you remember the
one that there was one was a bit where
Eric was talking about I'm getting so
over this point just so I don't carry
sort of historian Patrol oh so so he was
talking about he was like okay so when
you when you're setting up someone's
diet and period izing you want to have
let's say for example five low-calorie
days where you have moderate protein
moderate carbohydrate low fat and then
two days of reef eat where you have
higher carbohydrate and you you cycle
that through and Eric I'm sorry to
interrupt you but I've just got a
question pertaining to the
aforementioned status of of diet a
period izing that you just just
mentioned there and how would one how
would one implement take that along with
it a carb cycling protocol he was like
well I mean this kind of is carb cycling
it yeah so you need to be aware that
when you go to these things that people
might ask questions that are either too
nuanced or ones that whether trying to
sound too clever it's it's because of
the luck it like that they don't they're
coming at it from like that you need to
have some kind of goal of what am I
going to this for like am I going for my
own education in which case just sit and
listen if not if it's fantastic a
question that interests you but yeah
exactly and whereas if it's something to
make you a better personal trainer that
is not that it's never gonna be the
bottleneck unless you were like terrible
at what you do because most of the time
the the limiting factor with your
clients result is not protein synthesis
or like how their period their that
period or like how many grams of
creatine they have post-workout is it
pretty it's their compliance it's that
whole weekly volume it's your
environment seeing it be a human by
treating someone like a human of being a
human is like one of the biggest thing
is white what so why do you think this
is veering off I wanna get back to funny
stories in a second first three here
know that the secret to getting in good
shape isn't really a secret and it's
really quite basic
it's move more than you eat control the
processed foods that you have tried new
progressive overload trying to lift
heavy three times a week
trailer some sort of fresh air try and
get some daylight sleep well mmm-hmm
place it that's it why is the fitness
industry so abound with different
approaches to achieving that is it
because this is my theory is who you
think um the route from input to output
the process that people go through to
get there is so opaque and so difficult
to see that allows everyone to be like
what's in the magic box my magic box is
the faster quicker superior magic all
these only it's the only way to end this
like why is it allowing because it's a
[ __ ] industry you guys work in an
industry of charlatans yeah why it's
just its money its profit like whenever
in any and you can see this in anything
where the process is the answer the true
answer is like a few things done every
day for two years like saving money for
example like becoming wealthy the answer
is never like this foreigner it on a
course in a in a forex masterclass
there's all this technical analysis yeah
system of triggers and Asian points and
it's the fundamentals done for a very
long time and that and people don't want
to hear that and that creates a gap for
people who are really good at marketing
to make a lot of money cool and what
else we got
I want to hear what happened when you
went to go see James Smith cuz you've
identified the fact that you guys aren't
you there's two broadly two categories I
think of online yeowch yeah there's the
James Smith and there's the propane
thinners propane fitness would be more
analytical with regards to the way that
they've got sales funnel setup they're
using ads cleverly they're using spend
online we see it as where we're like the
other where the everyman option like not
everyone can be James Smith my
definition I think that's like everybody
trying to be on Coronation Street or
Holly oak or you know like you need to
be a certain type of person for that to
work if you make it great yeah you sort
it and it's easy to look back and go
yeah just you want to go to acting
school and if you can you can map out a
path that
you took to get there but actually the
reason is your charisma the way you look
that and James is obviously great at
that stuff and that was you know the
elephant in the room for us in that
entire seminar was like half the people
asking questions like they're they're
quiet they're shy and James naturally is
not that and that's gonna be the biggest
difference but but beside the point so
we we teach people a way to just not to
be run an academy with thousands of
people in it just how might you go about
replacing or you it as an offline coach
as an online coach and if you do the
same income in a way that was a bit
allowed you're not worth a lot more
flexibility that's a table for everyone
it's not going to make you a millionaire
but it's achievable and we do that with
like marketing sales the basics of mind
there's nothing that stops you from
doing what again my housemate Lewis is
looking at doing which is augmenting is
existing offline well yeah any go I mean
we've had many people that we've worked
with that if you know doubled or tripled
or like 1k a couple of cases like six
seven times their their income to like
so 10 10 15 grand a month but they still
want to do some offline personal
training stuff just gonna keep my foot
in the thing I know some clients I'd be
makes me just want to keep their foot in
the thing just for innovative yeah just
don't foot on the ground and like have
some love because they get some level of
satisfaction from it and what's better
is that they can then handpick the best
offline clients that they have yeah
charge a higher rate and just suck off
the pain-in-the-ass ones mmm and then
just focus on killing on work who else
who else you've been to see so you have
this very calm state what about what are
some of the other things that people
should be concerned about before they
sign up to a seminar oh my god like I
where to begin with that like some of
the things some of the situations I've
been in with Youssef like so it's hard
to describe because you have to the more
you know Youssef the funny the whole
trans but if Youssef is you gotta
remember the sort of guy who went to
Blythe is if Blythe we're difficult to
be in a cult where he ends up lying down
on the ground because everyone around
him was dancing and he didn't
but he still went for 12 weeks so like
if someone says this is the way to do it
user he'll do it the the first business
coach we hired told us to basically we
did like a boosted post Facebook art
which is not never you know it's a great
way you get a lot of exposure but it
literally just anybody can come into
your world there's no targeting or
measurability to anything you do and
that's what happened loads of people
booked one of these free coaching calls
with us which is what we're told to do
and we're good students so that's what
we did and we spent about I mean it
probably a hundred hours on the phone so
just to give you some context for this
as well like this is a man who was
bragging about the fact that he put
makes people bring people to tears
during the sales calls all the time
bragging that he got a single mom to
remortgage a house so that she could
sign up for his yeah it really is
Australians product it and the sales
script they give you is really
manipulative and really like just paying
point okay right yeah you're encouraged
to make people cry NLP and so we've been
doing this for a while would have mixed
success with it youssef lost a friend
over there I remember feeling like
nauseous while doing these calls it on
plus it's just so not in line with who
we are as people but we like what we've
got to follow the process could seek a
flat ground for it so you sucked in a
live on the court with this guy alive
roleplay where Youssef was the client
and this guy was trying to close
yourself and you surf just kept sitting
[ __ ] like it's five nine nine five
for my program you said was like okay
three guys that what do you think he's
no I think it's too expensive that's
like what do you mean by that well it's
beyond what I feel comfortable okay what
do you mean by that well it's I'm unable
to pay that today so I won't be
proceeding and they just continue and
we've been in so many like on the other
end of sales calls the gut guy trying to
sell us this program where he just kept
saying so what's next so he would say
something I start next to each his home
because I so you know this is the
program and so what's next
and you've just kept saying something
and it got to the end and the guy went
so what
guys what's next use of Tim means when
[Laughter]
it's just weird
Sushila sales calling both people have
been playing the game yeah yeah you
can't if one person just isn't bought
into the game the adversarial it's a I
suppose that the lesson is by the world
of people selling marketing advice to
personal trainers is really like that
there be dragons for sure like there are
people who have zero experience in what
they're teaching like have legitimately
never run a fitness business but see an
opportunity in this the same way in the
fitness world that Qatar people here
I've never bought anything from Grant
Cardone sir but he's Glen Carter how
seemed contra preneur I have yes yeah
yeah but not the interview the actual is
mentoring yeah yeah yeah is it supposed
to be Grant Cardone it is grant Carter
right okay I mean the the accents but
blatantly gives it yes he's got a mic
that says 11 X on it right oh right yeah
I'd be right ok so I mean in the same
way that there are people selling like
weight loss powder weight loss pills in
the fitness market there's the same
thing in in this market but it's more
when people are like messing with our
life savings or you know remortgaging
things because they've been sold this
dream gets a bit that's true like [ __ ]
lot of you really aware of like and I
suppose in the industry like once more
people are making money from selling how
to make money and then the thing itself
you've got a big you got a really where
it's a principle from Mike win it from
the Contra printer the whole principle
behind that is why if someone had the
secret would they turn their customers
into competitors mmm-hmm that's what he
asks like and yeah it's not quite a
zero-sum game but like there's only
especially where you're talking UK
audience mmm only 65 million people here
and that's for you I'm gonna guess
what's a good sized audience for you to
target three mail format for you
you mean on like on Facebook alone today
I mean like 400,000 would be
like a 1% of the UK audience minimum
like bottom end yeah I mean the thing is
okay so out of all of the people you
only have a hundred of them you only
have a hundred one percents yeah yeah
like that's not that many so that people
ask us this question a lot like if if
you're doing Fitness and it's going so
well why are you teaching personal
trainers and I definitely get where that
questions coming from because it feels
like yeah what the [ __ ] are you doing
you're scamming me yeah but the the
reality of the market is one most people
most coaches couldn't handle even a
hundred people online like the vast
majority so when you consider the market
when when you're in a when you're in
like Newcastle and you're a PT you
immediately think of it as well there's
me there's that gym down the road
there's that CrossFit gym and let's call
those mid-eighties and like you think in
a very competitive sense when you move
into the internet really anybody is a
client because most people or in Usos
world everybody has a bodybuilding goal
they just don't realize it
so like you can legitimately work with
anybody with internet connection seven
billion people yeah well and and when we
talk about Fitness injuries so big it's
huge because everyone going yeah we
talked about this idea of a freedom
number of the point at which you've
replaced your offline income with online
coaching and either double your income
or you can move into online coaching
full-time to get back you need like 20
people so like if all we do what do you
what's a typical charging you're
charging so you got 200 pounds a month
yeah between a hundred and two hundred
quid a month
it's like average online at them but for
a monthly rate so if we help even a
thousand people do that it's not even
putting like it's not even making the
tiniest dent in the fitness industry but
even in like the northeast of England it
would affect us and some people say that
you're like [ __ ] off you know do you
just sit and think about it for a second
do you think it's a it's a question for
you are you a better online coach coach
or an online co-op better online coach
with us with we're the same which the
material is different because ya know
like I you have you know our ability
yeah are you more talent into coaching
coaches or you maternity coaching
I think it depends for us for me
especially well fine for both of us it
depends on the fitness client because
we'll have some fitness clients who are
we went really well with people who are
like analytically minded so we'll have
some clients who come in who have
listened to a podcast then you give them
a little bit of information and you come
they come back and they've devoured all
of the members area all the podcast and
the shredded it's a bit like at least
alone in the kitchen with like a pot of
dry rice and a cookery book a garlic
clove and yeah like cookery book and
okay whatever and you come back and they
just made a feast with noodles and and
then with some other people so we I mean
you probably get this like we we aren't
like promoting like a juice fast diet or
like you're not I mean like we were
quite scientifically grounded were quite
numerical and are broadly beyond sexy
stuff it is exactly the unsexiest oh
thank God because we with two intolerant
as people to handle the type of person
that would come to you if you promoted
juice fasts because there's a type of
attitude and shortcut kind of mindset
it's very hard to shake if you have
someone that comes to you and once that
and then to try and coach them just
becomes impossible because it's just
like Square and that that exists in in
business as well but I think it's more I
think people thing how you marketers
well of course it does yeah but I think
all right there are a few people there
if that's another story as well there
are people who think like well by
tomorrow I'll have a big business online
like I think this order most people big
best or online big people think you know
it's gonna take a year or whatever and
so the result is a more serious type of
client then someone who's like select
well I'm going to holiday in ten days
don't get me Lady firemen ugly but yeah
yeah it depends on the client but
because probably because generally when
a PT comes to us I like guys serious
yeah this is gonna take two years but
that's fine like we're on the same page
if someone comes to us they're like
Youssef you're a doctor mate I want ABS
by and by next Monday can you
can you sort that there's nothing we can
do but give us the right fitness client
get you shredded fine okay that's good
that's a good politician's answer about
coaching coach is okay also like my
background is is Business and Finance
useless background is like bums and
breasts and sells hormones and glands
CEO mega dagger
so okay let's say we've talked about
kind of like what the environment is and
what the industry is like let's say
there's someone's thinking okay I'm
offline PT and ready to make the move
online or I'm someone who's got an
interest in health and fitness and I
think I should do that what's the first
step to they buy website no they make a
brand no absolutely
for God's sake no can i remortgage my
house no you're gonna we are this what
what are the most common things that
people think they should do buy a
website right so yes that and build a
program don't do that
so don't write don't build a program
don't get a website don't make a logo
don't definitely don't like pay someone
to set up a trainer eyes or my PT hub or
anything like that because all that is
doing is digging a trench in somewhere
where you're not sure whether the trench
is gonna actually be there long term
like you're building a house and you
haven't check the foundations and so we
we see this all the time and we like to
use it in marketing a lot that you see
someone post on Facebook on the personal
profile like I'm proud to announce after
six months of building it that I'm
finally launching my eight-week fat-loss
blaster program 0 comments 0 likes
tumbleweed six hours later and people
wonder why so the first thing to do is
really you want to build some sort of
sales process to test this with like
have an idea have a concept who do I
want to work with and why why would that
person listen to me
what compelling suffer I got to say to
that person what make the program looked
like then build a way to sell it to them
and sell first and building some people
bring in some people to stop reenroll of
them yeah or say if you were to post
online and say considering going online
is anyone looking for an online coach at
the moment why don't you give me
we'll have a chat and then you could say
you could talk to them to see the sort
of people who respond so you're talking
about dipping your toe in the water yeah
you want to build a program that is
designed for your clients not what you
think your clients need and that means
really you need clients to help you
build it
so should you start off just coaching a
few people for free that's one option
yeah the downside with that is a lot of
people don't take it seriously so like
someone we know actually it's just a try
to offer they know that you've seen this
he's just tried to off for 12 weeks of
coaching for free no one's taking up on
it and the reason is like people don't
if I said to you like I'll make you a
billionaire but it's free no problem but
suspicious yeah he just said well your
price is an indicator of course it is
yeah really really expensive like
whenever we've paid a lot for something
we like if you if you pay like or
something audio no more whatever you'll
you'll go do it because you like we'll
have to suck this mother but there's a
book in the marketing world called
breakthrough advertising that you can
only get now for like 800 quid and
everybody like gets really excited about
the book because it's so expensive it'll
just have the same stuff in its it's the
basics of marketing but like when things
are expensive people value them more so
something's free people tear it so how
do I find out who my audience is so that
I would serve you a year ago or you at
the beginning of your journey so I would
have that as your client because you are
like you you are that person post
transformation right broadly should men
coach men and women coach women for
effectiveness typically that's the
that's the best way to do it but yeah is
this difficult like if you have some
reasonable expertise in nothing fine but
when we like I get I feel it's weird
when I see like a 25 year old man say
that he's gonna do like middle-aged
women posts personal and you just know
what do you know what do you know about
that yeah about the struggles of a
middle-aged woman to begin a baby like
yeah it just it seems CD and it seems
like it is possible and some coaches are
really good at coaching yeah
medical movement yeah exactly and like
some men have really I'm sure have
really good postnatal programs but for
the first for your first on
program it's it's making it hard of
yourself because you have to imagine
what it's like to be that person so you
want to pick the goals that you had I'm
sorry so just the only exception to that
is if when you if just naturally from
your your existing personal social media
following you get loads of questions and
things from a specific demographic that
you and you can't figure out why then
fine so how do you have selected for men
women young people yeah and it could be
that you know James Smith is a very is
like a sexually desirable man and so a
lot of like a lot of women like him and
so they go for that they they message em
they see him as an authority and that's
who he's like right I'm just gonna I'm
his double Donald you were saying that
because James has got the mustache or do
the mustache is exactly that you're
hoping that messages you or me I think
he messages me yeah yeah you can meet
with me so a good example of this I got
a client last week launched his sales
funnel for his program there was men
only and more women bore than them like
so you know that he advertised it as a
mail program but he had more people
signups and mail size just like the
market going like do you think I should
rebrand it or got instinct so yeah like
so there are exceptions to that
definitely but the first thing to do
build a sales funnel might build a
webinar build a challenge and email
series something like that that
positions you as an authority gets you
to show off a little bit about what you
know and how you can help people and
offer your program as a I could pay to
launch at the end of it it's like I'm
doing this program I want and pick a
reasonable number of people like 20 or
whatever is reasonable for Half Price
and I just want some feedback I want you
to help me build it I want ideally a
testimonial and then the program that
you build is what they wanted rather
than like what Eric Helms spoke to you
about carp cycling in period a
management at a seminar because that
that's what everybody focuses on
gives a [ __ ] like someone will make it
an e-book about how branched-chain amino
acids work and then wonder why that
clients don't want it when their clients
are like middle-aged women so the exact
read like the fact that everyone that
was a PT and it wasn't Mayo for PTSD
Erica speaking yeah yeah and that's here
to try it and you're like well if you
look around in the room you think what
everyone here is a PT no one's what my
client would be mmm and so they're not
gonna care like if this room is full of
people that are my ideal client then
okay they're clearly interested in the
mechanics of copy acting so unclear then
use that better talk about carbs hoping
to get my clients and the stuff that
Johnny's mentioned there I think applies
for any result in any domain doesn't
have to be Fitness like just any
anything that you have expertise in and
you can get for other people that you
can knowledge that you can pack and
deliver and apply with someone keep them
accountable to that's that you know what
I the main issue I have with the grant
cardone stuff and like that I'm not just
grant cardone but like a lot of internal
marketing in general you might be might
not sure if you want something or [ __ ]
is this I think some of the time you
know people buy these courses because
that's hold are you gonna become an
internet millionaire but you still need
to have like you can put a turbo on to
anything but if it doesn't have like
wheels or chassis and engine it's never
does no one make go faster what's the
turbo you referring to turbo is later
learn what these people are teaching is
like a marketing mechanism usually like
a sales and marketing process for a
business online but Micra when it talks
about that he says that some woman
bought this grand cardones business
kickstart program for $3,000 who didn't
have a business yeah later a product
they're gonna help me come up with one I
mean that shaky for shaky ground begin
with there's no like you need you still
need it's still just demand and supply
in the market like just because you
bought something doesn't make you
instantly have a desirable thing whereas
if someone's a PT or it's the same as
you said for like trades or like if
you're an architect or a lawyer or are
speaking to someone the other week who
was a lawyer and now earns like
seven times what she end just working
for herself getting clients online love
it yeah so like there's an example of it
had she bought Grant Cardone or
something like that you know I have to
market yourself online when you have a
skill that is in demand it works so busy
you can't fabricate that by buying one
of these courses there's a really good
article don't I have a thought you might
send me it or something someone didn't
it was it was basically saying it was
like a was like article of the year or
whatever in it was just saying your
entire worth is determined by what value
you can I kill other people was a
judgment guilty guy that wrote this book
is full of spiders
okay society is the dying man on the
ground and you were the one that's
holding the pen knife yeah cool okay
yeah so so your thank you yeah so your
your entire worth is just what you can
offer to people and so I mean that's how
economics works is like demand supply
but people think like are dollar signs I
need to learn the marketing then you're
like what are you actually marketing
what's the other thing that were you
selling because there's a sense of like
I think what these things do is they
generate a sense of entitlement in
people that like well if I put myself in
front of the camera and then people will
will just buy my product because I'm
worthy of this and it's like well no
like not unless you actually have
something to wear if you look at like
two off all the legit businesses like
look at Amazon like Jeff Bezos didn't
have like a quick marketing funnel did
he like Elon Musk didn't start Tesla so
you send focus on the product I'm saying
all those people focused on having a
really solid product they were focusing
on the customers experience rather but
and this is the thing about like what
Johnny said about I'm launching my new
program and it's gonna be sick amazing
much better like latest intermittent
fasting no it's like people don't care
and you're not thinking of it from what
what do they want how can like because
they'll be watching you on video and
thinking well who's this guy how can
they help me I'm not interested in them
I'm interested in my big belly and I
want to get rid of it
it's rich isn't it with with regards to
when you you hear people and I see this
with myself as well like thinking about
I'm so in the weeds with my own
experience of life and my own life my
ability to have perspective on anything
that I do is almost zero yeah yeah yeah
like yeah you will talk to someone about
a project once that you've thought about
a thousand times we literally had a
thousand versions of this thought and
then when it comes to talking to them
about it you gobble your words because
there's so much to say hang on a [ __ ]
second yeah I mean oh no so how do how
do people ensure that they're kind of
still focusing on that is it focused
customer first so that that's what
people people mistake great product and
focus customer first with like right I
need to go into the like a cave and make
the best thing I can buy that might be
the best thing for you but it might not
be the best thing for the person buying
and that's why we're so big on like
there needs to be both there needs to be
a way to get these people to take you
seriously and actually pay you money
because if they don't pay money it's not
a business anyway but after that build
what they need like what is what is
gonna get them the best result possible
because the testimonials that you get
where someone like we have people like
videos of people saying we've changed
their life that doesn't come because we
explain to them how protein synthesis
works or like you know the little gave
them the latest in them in fact
something we gave them the solution to
their problem and I think that's what
and they'll tell you yeah like we're
just proud mom experiencing please help
me solve it and then you use the
expertise about brain synthesis and you
know a cinnamon finds justice all you
maater
but they don't want to know how it works
you know they'll give a [ __ ] how it
works a small subset of ones that do but
then they usually want to go and then
become pts and yeah you know don't eat
tales detail lift up call me with the
details isn't it layer cake yeah yeah it
is ought to be honest it is all just
like okay you both take [ __ ] get out in
the world take more [ __ ] welcome to the
load so one day you're up in the
rarefied atmosphere and you're an online
coach you're arriving with a blue tea
is something else that just I just
remembered was this was a link that
Johnny sent me about 42 minutes into a
Tom Martin seminar so you know you know
Tom Martin like for the listeners god
this is a guy who is with like mental
strong like he he deadlifted 340 are 82
kilos went up to 93 'he's got stupid
lifts everyone thought he was on drugs
it was like I was clearly on drugs like
look at his lifts one day he left the
powerlifting Federation that was drug
tested and became huge over six months I
started that dictate like who like like
400 plus squatting 300 plus likes really
big lifts and just thought looks like an
absolute like gone blue balls and full
it's how we have a very full tension and
there's like oh let's move to an
untested Federation and got very strong
so is it really impressive athlete like
absolutely mind-blowing and he sat there
um Arminius links he's tallest bicep
definitely delivering a seminar on like
basics of powerlifting and this guy goes
mr. your stop you never got your
question as a as a intermediate power
lifter who's recovering from an ACL
reconstruction if this was backing on my
left knee in 2014 and my question really
relates to the specifics of and the
mechanics of doing reverse band partial
squats in as part of my volume building
block and and so what's the efficacy in
implementing that within my program for
for competing like my squat is like have
you thought I just dude full orig squats
for the barbell like it's the it's yeah
the bet the basics is what and that's
what people don't want to hear what's
what's the one about the guy right now
you turned up to the internet marketing
explanation seminar and didn't have an
internet business
I may I'm not being funny right so yeah
so we're at a thing in we were a little
nutso where we were at a an event
somewhere in the UK on his first
location and someone came up to you sir
and you said it is not the person to ask
this question of because he doesn't like
it but it's life
does that make me I can ask you to ask a
couple of questions it was asked and
that's like loads of us questions I'm
not being funny about I'm not looking
fun can I ask you a couple of questions
about that yeah you have to answer it
how much you charge for like like loads
of like really cloak-and-dagger and it
got use I've got down to like the it was
like the brass man I don't mean very
similar he didn't have a website or
anything and that's like at the time I
wasn't we're so really advanced yeah
like I was like topper proper high end
talking about like packaging
intellectual rights and like it was that
like it was it was the assumption was
you had a website well it's familiar
with military precision face books and
yeah it wasn't it yeah super advanced
target is when you've been doing it like
seven years and you sit in a thing like
frantically taking notes that you know
really edge of your seat that's 150 life
and there's a bloke in the back like it
doesn't have a website like a community
hall somewhere in like to do West London
to like gluten gluten hams or something
rice a week for like a school sports
hall on a Saturday the Biddy he's there
cuz he wants he wants the answers and
that you know the fit my favorite thing
about the the James Smith event was so
the two things about that they were we
had one was like it's very similar to
the Tamar thing there's a guy on stage
he was done very well and he's doing
very well in the internet fitness world
and the questions were like James May
I've got I've got this woman who I
charged the
pounds an hour for thinking might charge
and 35 pounds an hour hey what do you
think and you want to start right
everybody sit the [ __ ] down
right this guy thousands of clients
online and you can come on charging
extra fiber per hour video it's when
people just start with a sprawling story
yeah sometimes it's not even a question
at the end of it you like you just put
your hand up there to just like have
your turn but yeah this is a [ __ ]
meeting grease mister Q&A speaking of
having your turn
so I'll ask a couple of questions and
you can see it was getting towards the
end of the day and I can wear Youssef
always feels like I need a participating
so G James is talking about is a guy
called the fitness chef does like
computer probably seen some of this
stuff comparison infographics of like
avocado on toast and yeah it's the same
I went to go and see recently Alain de
Botton in London and Douglas Murray
votre QA for them as well
yes at the end yes imagine I leaned upon
this man what this man's YouTube channel
has had 500 million plays 500 million
one of the most insightful channels on
the Internet and like he even he Alan is
like the most compassionate gentle he's
like the ultimate uncle you know mean
and
but on the way in the barbecue that the
waiter and even he caveated the
beginning of his Q&A section by saying
please keep questions to no more than
three sentences and please ensure that
they are a question that that's a man
who has experienced a lot yeah Marie
Douglas Murray said Alma he said two
sentences and make sure it's question
and there's still people that stand up
and go yes Douglas I wondered I wanted
first off thank you thank you for coming
I'm author thank you
first off obviously we are in
Westminster tonight it's like [ __ ] mate
what is this this is the only night the
problems or something for the framing
maybe this is your life
we've been here for two hours listening
to him and Lionel Shriver talk about
like the nuances of identity politics
for you to remind me that I mean
Westminster should just have like a bag
of marbles and you gotta throw a marble
every time so have you ever seen yet
this thing where there was people with
numbers in different areas of the room
and it was like number one two three
four five set he would just pick a
number and then they that person would
go it was like he's very Brown it's
delegate carried around the way but it
was like this one from this section and
one from this section and one from that
sector mate really this this kind of
vision of representativeness that you're
giving out here doesn't matter just like
everyone in that row yeah like just do
if there make it more complicated than
it needs it needs to be and okay so get
there and broadcast it be good and that
would be the most excited I'd ever be
but he'll take your wallet by the end of
the we will eventually okay so we've
given out some [ __ ] cool info today
um let's do a recap and also we need you
need to tell people where they can go to
to find out more from yourselves as well
so okay so I would say wait if if
someone is either so like gym owner
PT nutritionist offline or we have we
help a few
people who there's a few people actually
effectively in Fitness clients for two
years and are in such good shape that I
like I want to help people do the same
thing which is really cool
but so those criteria so you're off
you're outside the industry but thinking
about it offline PT gym owner anything
like that I I would start an online
presence regardless of whether or not
you wanted to be a full-time thing and I
would do it sooner rather than later
what's that mean like I would I would
have something in place I would have an
online program mode have an online
offering because really the barrier to
setting one up at the moment is pretty
low frictionless yeah and if you
especially if you have like clients
already it bolsters the value of your
offline service is it now there's a PDF
enough it's a weekly call enough I'd say
probably not but if we're gonna get into
that I've got it I've got a link that
can help people with that
so rather than me go through the deals
but yes
sooner rather than later just because
realistically there's someone starting
today now now now now and you're just
gonna be a year down the line if you
wait and there's no reason to wait
because everyone's always like are in
January or next year and the magical
land of when I have all the time and all
the money it's one of those things to do
with us being in the weeds about our own
experience again as well isn't it it's
like you presume that everybody else is
watching you yeah that you're going to
power one man that I got it when I wish
is hockey
yeah sick program yet cuz honestly if my
third cousin sees this thing and there's
a spelling error on the front page yeah
so doing he's getting started today
might mean in a year just doing alright
rather than you know this time next year
just beginning so start sooner rather
than later and don't get caught in the
weeds with websites and stuff you don't
need focus on what I said earlier and
just if you are getting help be very
careful so I the question we encourage
people to ask is like can I see your
version of this business please
like can I see if you're teaching me to
build a fitness business I want to see
this type of thing that I'm that I build
it because it might be like you might
see that this is something
that's weird that [ __ ] and and probably
the most common reason people give for
like I don't run my fitness business
anymore is like it didn't suit my
lifestyle so do you want to be taught by
someone he built the business they
didn't see the lifestyle just those
sorts of things
I don't I'm not trying to rubbish
everyone else because there are some
some really good coaches but just ask
for proof just like you would ask to see
someone's left at the part of the coach
or what I meant right and do your nails
no that's that's making muscles get
enough stuff can get make a must up make
it mustache you're sticking on stick it
on where so people are thinking this
under these suits are not they know what
they're talking about
mmm-hmm why should they go so propane
fitness lock-on forward slash modern
wisdom nice did it feel specially thank
you and that all that is is a it's
basically us as a case study so it's
appropriate fitness as a case study and
I just take you through what we did
because that's what people always ask
it's like what did you guys do when he
was dying
what were the set to you took so we've
broken it down into seven like our seven
key takeaways and it's free all sorts
very nice best thing that's [ __ ] I
didn't even know your name yeah thank
you
well for the listeners who are
interested in more or just want to get
something for free link will be in the
shot below our program Fitness comm
forward slash Muslims obviously fell
appropriate Fitness online all that good
stuff gentlemen its music thank you
thank you
[Music]
you